[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سي
ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي هو حديثكم فيه تقع
واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى في هذه اللحظات ينطلق في
استاد احمد بن علي في مدينه الريان
القطريه الشوط الثاني من لقاء منتخبي ويلز
والولايات المتحده لكره القدم ضمن مباريات
اليوم الثاني من كاس العالم قطر 2022
وتصل الى هذه الصور من محافظه شي ان جور
غربيه جزيره جا والاندونيسيه حيث تمكن
فريق الجزيره من الوصول الى المنطقه التي
ضربها زلزال خلف عشرات القتل ومئات
المصابين بحسب احصاء الاولي
وهذا الصور تريدنا مباشره من نيويورك حيث
يبحث مجلس الامن الدولي ملف التجارب
الصاروخيه التي تجريها كوريا الشماليه وما
تثيره من توتر لا سيما في شمال شرق اسيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
غداه غارات تركيه واسعه على مواقع حزب
العمال الكردستاني في شمال سوريا واقليم
كردستان العراق
اردوغان يتحدث عن تحضير لتنفيذ عمليه بريه
ويتهم موسكو بعدم الالتزام بالمساعده في
تطهير المنطقه من التهديد الارهابي وفقا
لاتفاقي سوتشي وقذائفه تستهدف جنوبيه
ولايه غازي عنتاب على الحدود التركيه تصفر
عن مقتل شخصين
[موسيقى]
ومن ايران الحرس الثوري يستهدف مقار داخل
اقليم كردستان العراق تابعه لاحزاب
ايرانيه معارضه ويقول انها مدعومه من
واشنطن وتل ابيب الخارجيه الايرانيه تدعو
بغداد واربيل الى تحمل مسؤولياتهما تجاه
ضمان امنها حكومه بغداد تقول ان الهجمات
تعد خرقا للسياده وبرلمان الاقليم يطالبها
بحمايه كل اراضي العراق
وسط مخاوف من تداعيات قصف محطه زبروج
النوويه خبراء الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه يؤكدونا حدوث اضرار ويواصلون تقييم
وضع المواد المشعه يدعو لحمايه دوليه
للمفاعلات من اي تخريب روسي وموسكو تتحدث
عن كارثه نوويه محتمله وتطالب المجتمع
الدولي بادانه واضحه للطرف المسؤول
يدعو لرفع الانفاق الدفعي لدول الحلف
الاطلسي والحفاظ على وحده مواقفها ورئيس
اللجنه العسكريه في النيتو يؤكد وجود نقص
في البنيه التحتيه على الجبهه الشرقيه
ووسط محادثات مكثفه بين برلين وبورسو
لنشري منظومه بيترياط للدفاع الجوي
مسؤولون في النيتو يتخوفون من ان تكون
بولندا هي الهدف التالي حال سقوط اوكرانيا
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقاميه ناقشنا اعتبارا الائتلاف المدني
من اجل الحريه والكرامه والعداله
الاجتماعيه والمساواه في تونس تقرير
الحكومه التونسيه المقدم اخيرا الى مجلس
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان مجانبا لواقع
الحريات في البلاد وقال انه يتضمن مو
غلطات علما بان تقرير تضمن دستور الخامس
عشر من يوليو
2020 والتعديلات التي ادخلت على المجلس
الاعلى للقضائي والهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات استطلاع اراءكم بشان هذا
الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في
رايكم هل عكس تقرير الحكومه التونسيه
حقيقه الوضع في البلاد ثمانيه وعشرون فاصل
اربعه في المئه قالوا انه يعكس فعلا الوضع
في تونس بين امراه
59.4% انه لا يعكسه واجابه 12 فاصل اثنين
في المئه بانه عكس وجزئيه هذا سؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه يمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري
على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وبعد الحصاد مباشره تحديدا في الساعه
12:05 بتوقيت مكه المكرمه تتابعون الجوله
الرياضيه ليوميه يوميات المونديال التي
ترصد بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم
قطر 2002 2010
الى مواضيع الحصاد قال الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان ان العمليات العسكريه التي
تنفذها قوات بلاده في شمال سوريا والعراق
لن تقتصر على الغارات الجويه اضاف اردوغان
ان نقاشات ستجرى بشان اشراك قوات بريه في
العمليه مشيرا الى ان المهمه تتلخص في
القضاء على المنظمات الارهابيه وفق تعبيره
وقد دعا الامين العام للامم المتحده لاقصى
درجات ضبط النفس وتجنب التصعيد الاقليمي
نظر مواجهه الاوسعه لحم مجددا بين انقره
وخصومها من الجماعات الكرديه المسلحه فبعد
يوم من غارات جويه تركيا على قواعد تلك
الجماعات في شمال العراق وشمال سوريا
تعرضت مدينه غرغامش في ولايه غازي عنتاب
الحدوديه لهجوم بالقضاء اسفر عن قتلى
وجرحى
القذائف التي انطلقت من الاراضي السوريه
اصابت مرافق مدنيه بينها بعض المدارس من
مقتضى تعطيل الدروس اسبوعا بحسب وزير
التربيه التركي اما وزير الداخليه فاتهم
حزب العمال الكردستاني بتنفيذ الهجوم
وتعاهد باستمرار عمليه الجيش التركي
على مناطق ماهوله في تركيا
ومعلمته من ضمن القتلى نؤكد ان العمليه
العسكريه التي بدات بالامس وسببت الكثير
من الخسائر للمنظمه الارهابيه ستستمر داخل
تركيا وخارجها
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك متحدثا عن احتمال اطلاق عمليه
بريه في الشمال السوري للقضاء على ما
سماها المنظمات الارهابيه ولم يخفي
اردوغان تدمره من عدم التزام روسيا باتفاق
سوتشي الذي ينص على تطهير المنطقه من
المسلحين الاكراد
كمشتكى من استمرار الولايات المتحده في
ارسال الاسلحه والذخائر الى ما سماها من
طاقه الارهابي في سوريا رغم ان البلدين
منضويان معنا تحت مظله 2
التحركات العسكريه جاءت بعد اسبوع من هجوم
اسطنبول الدامي الذي حملت انقر المسؤوليه
عنه للجماعات الكرديه حيث اعتقلت المراه
التي نفذ تفجير واعترفت وفق الامن التركي
بان حزب العمال الكردستاني هو الذي كلفها
بالعمليه وهي افادات تعدها انقره حجه ضد
نفي الحزب
مسؤوليته عن التفجير
اذا عمليه بريه تركيه يجري تحضير لها
شمالي سوريا ما هي الفصائل التي قد
تستهدفها واين تتمركز التفاصيل في هذا
التقرير
[موسيقى]
بين الجيش التركي وما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه يسخن المشهد على طول الحدود
السوريه التركيه داخل الاراضي التركيه
وقرب الحدود مع سوريا سقطت قذائف فوق
الضحايا قالت انقره انما سترها من تصفها
بالمنظمات الارهابيه في اشاره لما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وزاره الدفاع
التركيه قالت ان قواتها ردت قصف المدفعين
على تلك الهجمات كما نفذ الجيش التركي
ضربات جويه استخدمت فيها سيارات وسائل
اعلام مواليد لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه
مدنيه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ووزير داخليته اشار الى احتمال يقتصر رد
القوات التركيه على القصف المدفعي
والضربات الجويه بل قد يمتد الى عمليه
عسكريه في شمال سوريا فانقر تصنف بعض
مكونات قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والتي
تسيطر على مناطق واسعاره شرقيه وشمال شرقي
سوريا على انها نسخه وامتداد حزب العمال
الكردستاني المصنف ارهابيا وتلك القوات
مكونه من فصائل يشكل المسلحون الاكراد
الاغلبيه فيها كوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
ووحدات حمايه المراه اضافه الى فصائل اخرى
مقاتلوها من ابناء المنطقه العرب
والسوريان وغيرهم اشاره المسؤولين الاتراك
الى احتمال قيام الجيش التركي بعمليه بريه
شماليه سوريا لها حساباتها فالولايات
المتحده تدعم ما تسمى بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه خصوصا في معاركها ضد تنظيم
الدوله لكن رغم ذلك فان الجيش التركي قام
خلال السنوات الاخيره بعمليات عسكريه بريه
كبيره تمكن خلال هذا من اخراج المسلحين
الاكراد من المناطق الحدوديه سوريه وبعمق
عشرات الكيلومترات
من اسطنبول ينضم الينا الدكتور مسعود حقي
جاشن عضو مجلس الامن والسياسات الخارجيه
التابعه لرئاسه الجمهوريه التركيه ومن
مدينه اوستن في بلجيكا معناهوشنك اوسي
الكاتب والباحث في الشان الكردي مرحبا
بكما الدكتور مسعود حقي جيشن ما هي
الاعتبارات التي تحكم تحول هذه العمليه
الى عمليه عسكريه بريه تركيه
سيكون لها همم المنظمات الارهابيه هم يقوم
قاموا بتنظي هجماتين ارهابيه وعمليه تفجير
في اسطنبول قتل المدني واليوم قاموا
باطلاق الصواريخ وقتلوا اطفالنا ومعلمنا
ان استخدام الصواريخ ضد همم
ماشي والله هو يمثلوا
لقانون الدولي وايضا لون انتهاكا لسياده
التركيه وبالنظر الى اييي قانون الدوليه
الامن والسلام يجب ان يحترم حقل حكم
القانون والحياه المدنيه وان استهداف
المدنيين هو اخطر جريمه ضد الانسانيه
الارهاب
يستهدفين دكتور مسعود
يعني الان يتم تنفيذ ضربات جويه همم ضد
القوات الكرديه في داخل سوريا لماذا لا
يجري الاكتفاء بهذه الضربات الجويه وهناك
تلويح
بدخول بري بري
اه اوكي
هذه الاهداف بدقه ولا نستهدف المدنيين مع
ذلك هذا الامر سيستمر اذا ما نظرنا اذا
الى
كان هنالك اتفاق تم التواصل اليه مع الروس
والامريكان لكن نرى انهم يرسلون الكثير من
الصواريخ علينا ان ندفع نحو المناطق
الاخرى
لماذا
من المهمه
كان هنالك ان روسيا هي ضامن حامل الاراضي
السوريه ونحن ايضا قمنا بالكثير
لدعم سكان السوريين اكثر من مليون سوري
يعيش على اراضينا لكن
الدوله التركيه لا تحاول ان تهاجم
المدنيين نحن نهدي فوق الى دفعي
رفع هذه المنظمات واخلاقه هذه المناطق
الكاتب والبحث في الشان الكردي ضيفنا من
مدينه اوستند في بلجيكا كيف ستتعامل
القوات الكرديه والطرف الكردي مع هذا
التصعيد التركي ضدها
عن قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه بانهم
على الهجمات فقط
للعمليات العسكريه لكن يعني قليلا نبتعد
عن مساله ردود الافعال والتجاذب والحجاج
التي همم تطرحها تركيا همم وتبرر بها
عملياتها العسكريه همم حرصا على الامن
والسياده التركيه وهي في نفس الوقت تنتهي
امن والسياده همم دولتين هم سوريا والعراق
يعني
العمليات العسكريه التركيه القانون الدولي
همم التهاب سافر وسارق للسياده السوريه
العراقيه هذه الحجه لو كانت حقيقيه
ومنطقيه همم الدرجه الاولى همم
حزب العمال الكردستاني موجود في ايران
ايضا لنرى تركيا يعني لماذا لا تكشف
وضعتها
السلطات التركيه التركيه تقول انها ترد
على الهجمات من هذه القوى الكرديه في داخل
سوريا بما ان هي مستهدفه واا رايت العمليه
في شارع الاستقلال في داخل تركيا
تستخدم الحل العسكري فيما يتعلق بك كيف
همم يعني مكافحه حزب العمال دوله بهذا
الوزن بهذا القوه في حفظ الشمال الاطلسي
في الشرق الاوسط على امتداد 40 سنه
استخدمت نفس الاسلوب وفشلت في مكافحه حزب
العمال الثاني ماذا يعني ذلك يعني هل
تواصل دوله استخدام وسيله فاشله همم
لتحقيق اهدافهم بانها يعني اهداف قوبيه
ووطنيه
من اسطنبول
ما هي الخيارات الان امام القوات الكرديه
اما هذا التصعيد الذي يبدو انه يتوسع من
جانب تركيا بالتلويح بعمليه بريه
ما هي الخيارات المستوى
[موسيقى]
في ما يتعلق بمقاومه ما هي امكاناتهم ما
هي مستويات التسليح لديهم لا اعلم بذلك
انا لست خبير عسكري انا او احلل الموضوع
واحلل المشكله الكرديه اعتبارها مشكله
مزمنه في تركيا لا تتعلق بحسب العمال
الكردستاني القضيه الكرديه موجوده في
تركيا قبل حزب العمال
الدوله التركيه لكن الحلول التركيه لهذه
القضيه هي كانت حلول فاشله حتى الان وحتى
حزب العمال الكردستاني
ما ردك على هذا الكلام من ضيفنا من ان هذه
الحلول متكرره منذ 40 عاما وهي تفشل في كل
مره
نعم نوادر
تماما نحن استخدمنا الفقره 51 اختفاء على
نفسه حسب القانون الدولي اذا ما قام طرف
بقاء استهداف المدنيين في بلدك فانت لديك
الحق الدفاع عن نفسك ودائما ضدنا هذه
الفكره ان حزب العمال لا يمثل الشعب
الكردي نحن نحترم الشعب العربي والشعب
الكردي على حد سواء انا اقول ان اربع
هنالك ان اكراد السوريين يعيشون في بلادنا
ونحن نعيش لمئات للسنوات
همم الى همم
المدنيه من الذي يقتل مدنيين اليوم هنالك
اناس ابرياء تم قصفهم وقتلوا قاتله معلمه
في اسطنبول كان هناك طفله قد قتلت علينا
ان نعرف وان تماما من يستهدف المدنيين هذا
الامر همم القانون الدولي يعطينا هذه
السلطه نحن
حاولنا
ايضا بالتالي التركيه ايضا مصممه على قضاء
على هذه المنظمات الارهابيه همم
الترجمه الترجمه
الى
استهداف المدنيين هذه عمليات ارهابيه ليس
هذا امر لا يختلف عليه القانون الدولي
شكرا لك دكتور مسعود حقي جاشا عضو مجلس
الامن والسياسات الخارجيه التابعه لرئاسه
الجمهوريه التركيه من من اسطنبول وشكرا من
اوستن في بلجيكا هوشن الكردي
[موسيقى]
هكذا كان المشهد من الجانب التركي فماذا
عن الجانب الايراني فقد نفذ الحرس الثوري
الايراني ضربات صاروخيه وغارات بطائرات
مسيره ضد مقر تابعه لاحزاب ايرانيه معارضه
داخل اقليم كردستان العراق من جهتها اوضحت
وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه ان اربعه صواريخ
سقطت فجر اليوم على مقر الحزب الديمقراطي
لكردستاني الايراني في محافظه اربيل
بالتزامن مع تعرض حزب جمله قرب سليمانيه
لهجمات بطائرات مسيره مفخخه
وقال العميد علي فدوى نائب القائد العام
للحرس الثوري الايراني ان ايران حذرت
الحكومه العراقيه وحكومه اقليم كردستان
العراق من انها
ستستهدف مقرات من سماهم اعداء الثوره ما
دامت داخل الاراضي العراقيه وتستهدف الشعب
الايراني اضاف انه على العراق اخراج تلك
المجموعات من اراضيه وان ايران لن تستهدف
سياده ووحده الاراضي العراقيه وانما مقار
تلك المجموعات المسلحه واتهم فدوى واشنطن
وتل ابيب بدعم هذه المجموعات وبالتامل على
بلاده واوضح ان القوات الايرانيه تقوم
بالرصد الاستخباراتيه وتحديد اماكن
المسلحين قبل اي عمليه حتى لا تستهدف
المدنيين
دعا المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني حكومتي بغداد واربيل الى تحمل
مسؤولياتهما تجاه ماسمه حق ايران في ضمان
امنها على الحدود مع العراق
القومي نحن نحترم وحده العراق وسيادته لكن
ينبغي الا تسمح اربيل لجماعه انفصاليه في
تصدير السياحي الى مدير الشغب والارهابيين
في ايران
فيها عقدنا خلال الشهر الماضي مع مسؤولينا
امنينا من البلدين في طيران بغداد
في بغداد وحكومه اربيل في اقليم كردستان
العمل بالمسؤولياتهما تجاه حقنا في ضمن
الحدود
العراق
كردستان الحكومه العراقيه الى الوفاء
بواجباتها الدستوريه في حمايه سياده
العراق بما في ذلك اقليم كردستان واتخاذ
كل السبل اديبلوماسيه لتحقيق ذلك في بيان
اليوم دانه فيه بشده الهجمات الايرانيه
على الاقليم داعيا مجلس الامن والمجتمع
الدولي للقيام بواجباتهما لحمايه امن
المنطقه والعالم والحد من عدم الاستقرار
اما وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه فاعرضت عن
رفضها رفضا قاطعا القصف الايراني
بالطائرات المسيره والصواريخ على اقليم
كردستان واكدت الوزاره ان الهجمات
المتكرره التي تنفذها القوات الايرانيه
والتركيه بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره على
اقليم كردستان تعد خرقا لسيادته العراق
على طولي 1460 كيلو متر تمتد الحدود
الايرانيه العراقيه
ربع هذه المسافه يشهد توتر ليس الاول من
نوح عنوانه هذا التوتر احزاب كرديه
مستقره في اقليم كردستان العراق
يقول الحرس الثوري الايراني
[موسيقى]
بعمليه قصف مراكز هذه الاحزاب في الاقليم
العراقي تركزا القصف الايراني والاخير على
محافظه السليمانيه في السليمانيه يقصف
الحرس الثوري الايراني
للحزب الديمقراطيه لكره الديستانيه
ايرانيه تطالب طهران حكمتي بغداد واربيل
بتحمل المسؤوليه وحمايه الحدود ترفض حكومه
كردستان العراق القصف والتنفي الاتهامات
بتهريب اسلحه عبر الحدود وتدين القياده
الامريكيه الوسطى الضربات الايرانيه وتتهم
طهران بتعريض امن المنطقه للخطر هكذا تبدو
350 كم من الحدود بين العراق وايران مسرح
توتر تتداخل فيه اطراف كثيره
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من سهران محمد صالح
صدقيان الباحث والمتخصص في القضايا
الاقليميه ومن بغداد هاني عاشور الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما همم محمد صالح
صدقيان عندما يتحدث الجنرال علي فدوي عن
انه جرى عن ان ايران حذرت العراق وسلطات
اربيل من انها ستستهدف مقار هذه المجموعات
ماذا نفهم من وراء ذلك ما حدود ونطاق هذا
التحذير الذي يشارك
مساء الخير ليكي ولضيفك وللمشاهدين يعني
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي تحذر فيها
طهران من تواجد عناصر تابعه للحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني الذي يعرف
مختصرا الكولا وبالتالي هذه المجموعات
التي سلطات الايرانيه وثائق تدعم وجود مثل
هذه المقرات والمعسكرات داخل اقليم
كردستان العراق قبل شهرين او شهر الماضي
تحديدا كانت هناك كان هناك اجتماع رئيسه
وفد قاسم الاعرجي مستشار الامن القومي
العراقي راسا وفد من المخابرات العراقيه
والجيش العراقي ووزاره الداخليه وبيشخص
وزير الداخليه في اقليم كردستان ومن
القوات الامنيه في كردستان وهي قوات
الاسايش جاءوا الى طهران وايضا كان هناك
اجتماع سابق في بغداد
اتفق الجانبان الايراني والعراقي اتفقوا
على ضروره نزع السلاح من العناصر عناصر
الكوموله التي لديها اكثر من معسكر في
اقليم كردستان العراق
وطالب وايضا واتفقوا على ينزع السلاح من
هذه المقرات لمده لمده 10 ايام لكن ذلك لم
يحدث وبالتالي الحكومه العراقيه تقول
بانها لا تستطيع ان تدخل اراضي اقليم
كردستان ويحملون جانب الكردي على ذلك الان
مره اخرى هناك معلومات والايرانيون
السلطات الامنيه الايرانيه حصلت على
معلومات بتهريب السلاح من كردستان العراق
الى داخل محافظه كردستان الايرانيه وادخال
عناصر ايضا من اجل استغلال الاحتجاجات
التي تحدث في هذه المدن على خلفيه مقتل
وفاه المرحومه مساء امي وتستغل هذه
الاحتجاجات من اجل اولا التسليح
الاحتجاجات ثانيا احداث فوضى وشغب في مدن
كردستان ايران وكلنا يعلم بان كومالا هدفه
واضح وهو انفصال محافظه كردستان الايرانيه
عن الاراضي الايرانيه وهذا شيء خطير جدا
بالنسبه للامن القومي الايراني وللامن
الايراني وهو خط احمر بالنسبه للسلطات
شكرا لكم
كرديه الايرانيه موجوده في العراق منذ عده
سنوات وفي هذه الاماكن وفي هذه المعسكرات
ولم تكن قد صنفت عن ذلك انها تقوم باي عمل
داخل الاراضي الايرانيه ولكن المثير في
الامر حقيقه والذي اثار هذه القضيه هو
تصريحات المستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
السابق
في الثامن من هذا الشهر عندما تحدث
للبي بي سي القسم الفارسي وقال ان هناك
اسلحه تهرب من اقليم كردستان العراق على
يد جماعه كرديه ايرانيه الى داخل ايران
وتهدف الى اسقاط النظام الايراني حقيقه
هذا التصريح كذبته حكومه كردستان العراق
بشده وعبره اكثر من بي صدر عنها ولكن يبدو
انه اخذ حيزا كبيرا لدى الاداره الايرانيه
بان حقيقه هذه الاحزاب تقوم بتهريب
الاسلحه الى داخل كردستان ايران
سيد محمد
صالح ان اجتماعات امنيه جرت بين الطرفين
العراقي والايراني بحيث طلب اجانب
الايراني من العراقيين التعامل مع هذه
الاحزاب ولم يحصل ذلك امم كيف يفترض الان
ان تتعامل ان يتعامل او تتعامل السلطات
العراقيه مع ما يحدث ومع ما يجري
السؤال موجه لي انا الصوت تقريبا يتقطع
نعم اولا نحن لدينا تجربه في العراق
شاهدناها عام 2004 2005 عندما كان هناك
منظمه مجاهد خلق موجوده في العراق وايضا
تم استهدافها والنتيجه ان القوات
الامريكيه كانت انا ذاك هي التي تسيطر على
الساحه العراقيه فقامت هي بالتفاوض مع
جهات ايرانيه وجهاد حكوميه عراقيه ومن ثم
نقل مجاهد خلق الى خارج العراق في دول
اخرى في اوروبا هذه المره يبدو ايران تريد
ان يحدث نفس الشيء من خلال هذا الضغط ولكن
حقيقه الحكومه العراقيه المركزيه
ليس لديها قوه داخل اقليم كردستان هي لا
تستطيع ان تحمل حدود كما تطالب ايران بذلك
المفروض ان ايران هي التي تحمل حدودها
وتمنع اي الى اراضيها ولكن هذه المره يبدو
ان الضغط الايراني ليس فقط مركز على هذه
الجماعات الكرديه وانما يتناغم ايضا مع ما
تقوم به تركيا في مواجهه حزب العمال
الكردستاني الموجود بالعالم
العملي
ات التي تقوم به ضد هذه المجموعات الكرديه
في داخل العراق
يعني هناك معلومات ووثائق اكثر من 70
وثيقه لدى الايرانيين بالاضافه الى قول
جوبلتن الايرانيون تقدموا بهذه قدموا اكثر
من مره هذه الوثائق الى سلطات العراقيه في
بغداد والى سلطات الاقليم المشكله ان
ايران لا تريد ان
يحمي العراقيون
الحدود العراقيه الحدود العراقيه المشتركه
مع ايران في اقليم كردستان المشكله ايران
تقول بان هناك معسكرات هذه المعسكرات
معسكرات تدريب ومعسكرات سلاح وهذه
المعسكرات تنقل العناصر والاسلحه الى داخل
الاقليم خلال الشهرين الماضين همم ايران
قبضت على اسلحه وخلايا همم اراده استغلال
الاحتجاجات في محافظه كردستان ايران
وبالتالي ايران لا تريد الحفاظ على الحدود
المشتركه هي تريد
تريد اغلاق هذه المعسكرات
يقولون بان هذه معسكر
الان برلمان كردستان يطلب من الحكومه
المركزيه القيام بحمايه السياده العراقيه
على كل الاراضي كيف تتعامل السلطات
العراقيه المركزيه مع هذا المطلب
غدا صباحا ستكون هناك جلسه للبرلمان
العراقي
بطلب من القوه والاحزاب الكرديه وهذه
الجلسه مغلقه
وسوف يستضيف البرلمان بها قاده عسكريين
وامنيين عراقيين للخروج بقرار موحد يمثل
البرلمان العراقي والحكومه العراقيه وانا
لا اعتقد ان ما سيخرج به البرلمان العراقي
سيختلف كثيرا عن بيان وزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه هذا اليوم وبيان حكومه اقليم
كردستان الخارجيه العراقيه اكدت على موضوع
حسن الجوار واحترام السياده العراقيه
وفنادت المعلومات التي تقول ان ما يجري في
اقليم كردستان من قبل الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه ومن خلال تهريب سلاح فندت هذه
الحقائق ولكن نحن نقول ايضا ان الحكومه
الايرانيه يجب ان تحمي حدودها وهي تدرك
تماما وقد طلبت هذا الامر من الحكومه
العراقيه لاكثر من مره ولكن القوات
العراقيه لا تدخل في اقليم كردستان لان
البيشمركه وهو القوه الكرديه هو الذي يحمي
حجما كردستان في امام ايران
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نستعرض المواقع
التي تعرضت لها جامعه تركيه وايرانيه
ونسال ضيف الحصاد عن السياق الجيو السياسي
لهذه العمليات وتداعياتها
[موسيقى]
حضرت الحكومه اليمنيه من استمرار الحوثيين
في استهداف المرافق المدنيه والمنشات
الاقتصاديه الوطنيه واعتبرت ذلك تصعيدا
خطيرا من شانه مفاقمه الوضع الانساني
اضافت ان ما وصفته بالميليشيا الحوثيه
اقدمت على هجومها بالطائرات الايرانيه
المسيره مستهدفه بناء الضب النفطي في
حضرموت اثناء الرسوبي احدى السفن النفطيه
التجاريه غير مكترسه بمخاطر واثار
اعتداءاتها وقالت وزاره الدفاع اليمنيه ان
دفاعتها الجويه اعترضت واسقطت عددا من
الطائرات مسيره المعاديه التابعه لجماعه
الحوثيين اوضحت ان احداها اصابت منصه
تصدير النص في ميناء الضبه النفطي لمحافظه
حضر موت والحقت بها اضراراديه
من ناحيته قال المتحدث العسكري للحوثيين
نقواتها اجبرت سفينه نفط حاولت الاقتراب
من ميناء الضبه جنوب شرقي اليمن على
المغادره
من اكسفورد ينضم الينا اسامه الروحاني
نائب المدير التنفيذي في مركز صنعاء
لدراسات الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك اسامه
الروحاني ماذا وراء هذا الاستهداف
الحوثيلي ميناء الضبابه باعتقادك
هذا ليس بالاستهداف في الاول وهذا ترى
استهدافات سابقه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه وهذه تاتي في اطار
مقاربه مختلفه للحوثيه عندما يعرف اليوم
جيدا انه لا يمكن ان يحدث اي تقدم عسكري
على
الخطوط التماسك البريه وانه وصل الى مكان
مغلق ولا يمكن ان يحقق اي استحقاقات
سياسيه او عسكريه حتى ااه حتى هذه اللحظه
ولذلك
الى الجزئيه الاولى هو ان
يهدد همم
الحركه همم الملاحيه سواء في المياه همم
الخاصه باليمن او حتى في المياه الدوليه
او الجزئيه الاخرى ويحاول من خلال ذلك ان
يقدم نفسه ليوم كلاعب اقليمي ويحاول ان
يفرض هذا ليس فقط بعامل تهديد وهذا نوع من
التهديدات التعامل معه العالميه وهنا
يحاول الحوثي ان يح على همم على مكاسب
سياسيه وعلى مكاسب حيث ايضا حضور في
المشهد العام بشكل او باخر ياتي ذلك همم
في فتره نرى ان الحوثي اليوم فيها هو اقرب
الى ايران منديسابق وهنا قاسم المصالح
والنشاطات الاقليميه سواء حتى تحديد على
المياه الاقليميه وخصوصا ان هناك همم
هناك همم سفينه مركز همم مركز رئيسي
للحركه الملاحيه الايرانيه متواجده في
البحر الاحمر قباله همم المياه اليمنيه
همم من اتجاه محافظه الحديده همم في نفس
الوقت همم نرى ان الحوت اليوم يسيطر على
اكثر من 30 جزيره في همم البحر الاحمر
الجزء اليمنيه لذلك هو يحاول بذلك يوم ان
يقدم نفسه ليست على القوه الاقليميه في
المنطقه او يقدم نفسهم كذلك انما ايضا على
على الجراحه الدوليه بشكل عام بالنظر همم
الاجواء الاقليميه عموما هل ينجح في هذا
المساء باعتقادك
انا اعتقد عندما يغيب الضغط المحلي على
جماعه الحوتي ويعتقد انه هو الاقوى اليوم
في ضمن الانقسام الجهه المراهقه له اعتقد
انه سيرى نفسه همم اكثر نشاطا في هذه
الزاويه وكما اشلت ولا ليس لا يمتلك قوه
بارده وانما يمتلك عوامل التهديد عن
استخدام الطائرات المسيره وعبر عمل ازعاج
في المياه الاقليميه والدوليه وهذا سيضع
المجتمع البدوي المجتمع مع الاقليمي امام
الخيارين اما ان يصل الى تفاهمات مع
الحوثي او ان يرد على الحوثي بطرق مختلفه
ليست فقط بالتدخل المباشر بعد هذه المياه
وانما اعيد عبر تقويه
القوه المناهضه داخل اليمن ولا نراه هنا
اليوم ان هناك رد فعل من الحكومه اليمنيه
وان كانت ما زالت في مرحله التصريحات لا
اكثر لا في مرحله همم شيء على ارض الواقع
وهنا همم يجب ان نرى الايام القادمه اذا
ما ستكون الحكومه قادره فعلا ان همم
تصعد عسكريا بشكل او باخر وان تق جماح
الحوثي في الداخل وتشغله في المعارك
الداخليه حينها سيضعف النشاط الاقليمي
والدوري شكرا لك اسامه الروحاني نائب
المدير التنفيذي في مركز صنعاء للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه من اقصدرد
[موسيقى]
دعا الرئيس الاوكراني
شمال الاطلسي النيتو الى ضمان حمايه
المفاعلات النوويه الاوكرانيه من اي تخريب
روسي وقال ان من مصلحته جميع الدول الا
تقع اي احداث خطيره في المنشئه اضافه
زنسكي في كلمه عبر الفيديو خلال الجلسه
العامه للجمعيه البرلمانيه لحلف الناتو
بمدريد ان العدوان يهدد الجميع وعلى نيته
ادراج روسيا في قائمه الدول الارهابيه حسب
تعبير تعبير
يا كيف اود ان يتم في بلدانكم وفي
برلماناتكم تعريف روسيا على انها دوله
ارهابيه كما اود ان توصل بلدانكم الحفاظ
على العقوبه المفروضه على روسيا اعتقد ان
العقوبه مهمه جدا من اجل منع استمرار هذه
الحرب وان تمتد تلك العقوبات وقتا طويلا
نحتاج الى حزم جديده من العقوبه ضد روسيا
بسبب هذه الحرب الارهابيه
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه
الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه الى اتخاذ
موقفا مسؤول ومطالبه سلطات الاوكرانيه
بوقف قصف محطه زبوجيا لطاقه النوويه وقالت
زاروبا في بيان مشير على موقع الوزاره انه
يجب الابتعاد عن الادارات والمطالب
المجرده بوقف قصف محطه زبوجيا دون الاشاره
بوضوح وبدون لبس الى اولئك الذين نفذ
الهجمات
من عمان معنا اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء فايز
ما حجم الخطوره التي تحيط بمحطه زبروجا
باعتقادك في ضوء هذا القتال والاستهداف
العسكري لها
اجابه على هذا السؤال المدير الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه عندما قال الوضع خطر جدا
لماذا لان
القذائف التي اطلقت في هذا اليوم اصابت
بعض المناطق المحيطه
بالمفاعلات النوويه المفاعلات النوويه لم
ل همم لم تصب معدل الاشعاع لا يزال طبيعي
لكن قسم منها فقط في منطقه ما يطلق عليه
اليورانيوم المنضب وهو بعشرات الاطنان ان
لم يكن بمئات لانه لا يوجد رقم دقيق حول
كميه اليوراني ومنظم
هو همم يبعث طاقه اشعاعيات عادل 60% من
اليورانيوم الطبيعي
وتقريبا همم هو همم تعتبر طاقته همم فاصله
سبعه واحد واحد بالمئه بالمئه لكن رغم ذلك
يحتوي 204 يورانيو 234
235 لكن هذه النسبه فاصل سبعه واحد واحد
هي ل 235 فيما تقريبا 99.7
ليورانيوم 238 فهذا يمكن ان يسبب كارثه
ويعيد العالم الى كارثه تشيرنوبل
السيناريو مكرر حدث ذلك قبل اشهر عندما
جرى القتال بالقرب من المحطه ذهب رافاييل
جروس بنفسه مدير الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه لتفقد المحطه وجرى الحديث عن انه
سيتم همم نزع السلاح من حول هذه المحطه
لتجنب هذه المخاطر لماذا فاشله كل هذا
السيناريو وعودنا الى همم هذا الاستهداف
لها
لانه حتى هذه اللحظه
كل طرف يتهم الطرف الاخر
هلا المتحدث باسم
الروسيه تتهم والمتحدث العسكري يتهم
اوكرانيا انها وراء عمليات الاستهداف
وتطالب الوكاله الدوليه ان تقوم بواجبات
الحقيقيه ولا تكتفي بالادانه همم فيما
الجانب الاوكراني يتهم الجانب الروسي الان
الحقيقه هي الضحيه وهي الغائبه ولهذا
السبب الوكاله الدوليه لا تملك قوه
تنفيذيه لي من اجل ذلك هي تتقدم بتوصيه
لاخلال منطقه المحيطه من اجل امن الطاقه
لكن يبدو ان هناك استهداف قد تكون
الترجيحات بناءا اعتمدنا على التصريحات
الروسيه التي تدعو للشفافيه قد يكون
استهداف اوكراني انا لا استطيع ان اجزم
بذلك لانه اوكرانيه وتتهم روسيا الان ما
دور الاقمار الصناعيه ما دور الاقمار
الصناعيه المعنيه بم قبض كل حركه على
الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه لانها مغطاه على
مدار 24 ساعه لماذا لا تقدم الدول التي
تملك هذه القدرات هذه القدرات الاستشهاريه
لماذا لا تقدم المعلومه الحقيقيه علما ان
الامر همم يعتبر خطر جدا يوجد سته مفاعل
مفاعلات تنتج تقريبا
567 ميجا 1000 ميجاوات وبالتالي همم رقم
خيالي هذه هذه المفاعلات تقدم
50% من انتاج الكهرباء المعتمد على
المفاعلات النوويه في اوكرانيا وتنتج خمس
الطاقه الكهربائيه بالمجمل في اوكرانيا
اذا نحن نتحدث عن سته مفاعلات كل مفاعل
شكرا جزيلا لك
فائده
من عمان
طلب الرئيس الاوكراني حلف الشمال الاطلسي
بفرض حزمه جديده من العقوبات على روسيا
جاء ذلك في كلمه القاها الرئيس الاوكراني
عن بعد خلال انعقاد جلسه الجمعيه العامه
للنيتو في العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد من جهه
حث الامين العام للحلف على عدم السماح
للرئيس بوتن بالانتصار في الحرب وتتزامن
هذه الدعوات مع رفض كيف حتى اللحظه لدعوات
امريكيه غير مباشره للانخراط في مفاوضات
مع روسيا من اجل انهاء الحرب
اوكرانيا لن يدعى روسيا تنتصر في الحرب
هكذا اسمع الجميع خلال الجلسه الجمعيه
العامه لحلفي شمال الاطلسي في مدريد اجمع
الحضور على المفهوم الاستراتيجي للحلفي
وعلى زياده المساعده لقوات اوكرانيا
كلمه الرئيس الاوكراني عن بعض تضمنت
مطالبه قديمه وجديده
على انها دوله ارهابيه كما اود ان توصل
بلدانكم الحفاظ على العقوبه المفروضه على
روسيا اعتقد ان العقوبه مهمه جدا من اجل
منع استمرار هذه الحرب وان تمتد تلك
العقوبات وقتا طويلا نحتاج الى حزم جديده
من العقوبه روسيا بسبب هذه الحرب
الارهابيه داخل هذه القاعه رددت جمله
الحرب ستكون مكلفه وطويله هل يعني ذلك
اغلاق الطريق امام المفاوضات الدبلوماسيه
لانهاء الصراع طبابيا ومتناقضا احيانا
يبدو النقاشه بشان الرغبه او المساعد
الامريكيه من اجل جلوس طرفي الحرب
المباشره الى طاوله التفاوض وقد تعكس
الرسائل المباشره والمبطنه بهذا الخصوص
وجوده خلافات داخل نفسها ولكن لا يراد لها
ان تظهر للعلم واشنطن حريصه دائما على
الحفاظ على صوره الحلف المتماسك منذ نشوب
الحرب تكرر ان الامر متروك للرئيس زيلانكي
ليقول ما اذا كان مستعدا للمفاوضات ومتى
وما الشكل الذي ستتخذه تلك المفاوضات
والمفارقه ان البيت الابيض لم يعارض
تصريحات الجنرال مارك ميلي التي تحدث فيها
عن ضروره اغتنام فرص التفاوض لتحقيق
السلام
التفاوض واشبه بطلب استسلام اوكرانيا علق
في وقت سابق مستشار الرئيس
الاخيرسون وجبهات اخرى البدايه لاستعاده
كل اراضيها من القوات الروسيه بنظر بعض
حلفائها تقدمها العسكري فرصه قد لا تتكرر
للدخول في حوار مع موسكو من منطلق قوه
ضعف حتى وان جهر الغرب ان القرار بيدك يف
الكل يعلم ان اليد التي تقدم المال
والسلاح في الحرب هي اليد العليا في مسائل
كثيره ومنها الحوار الدبلوماسي لانهاء
الحربي المكلفه جدا
[موسيقى]
عوده الى تلويح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان باطلاق عمليه بريه في سوريا غداه
سلسله من الغارات الجويه على مواقع
للاكراد في سوريا والعراق وعده هجمات
صاروخيه على الاراضي التركيه من سوريا فقد
اطلقت تركيا عمليه عسكريه استهدفت مواقع
لحزب العمال الكردستاني الشماليه العراق
في جبال قنديل وسوس وهاكورت كما استهدفت
الضرباته وقواعد لوحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه في عين العرب كوباني رفعت
والجزيره
في سوريا وبحسب الرئيس التركي فقد اشتركت
في العمليه سبعون طائره ومسيره وتوغلت
الطائرات المهاجمه 140 كم في شمال العراق
و20 كيلومترا شماليه سوريا وفي سوريا
استهدف القصف مناطق حدوديه وسيطر عليها
قوات الديمقراطيه وعمودها الفقري وحدات
وحمايه الشعب الكرديه لا سيما في مدينتي
كوباني في الشمال والمالكيه في شمال الشرق
وكانت تركيا قد اعلنت ان قذائف مصدرها
مناطق سيطره ما تعرف بوحدات حمايه الشعب
الكردي التي تصنفها انقره بالارهابيه قد
سقطت على منطقه خميس التابعه لولايه غازي
عنتاب الحدوديه وهم اسفر عن سقوط قتلى
وجرحى
نبقى مع الاكراد المعارضين ولكن هذه المره
لطهران فخلال الساعات الاخيره استهدف
الحرس الثوري الايراني مواقع تابعه لاحزاب
كرديه معارضه في شمال العراق علما ان هذه
الضربات تكررت منذ سبتمبر الماضي وهي
مرشحه للتصعيد تنتشر الجماعات الكرديه
الايرانيه المعارضه لنظام سهران داخل
القرى والبلدات الحدوديه العراقيه ويقدر
العدد الاجمالي لافراد تلك الجماعات بسبعه
الاف شخص
ابرز تلك الجماعات هي الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني حتى هو اقدمها و تاسس
عام 1945 في ايران ويتبنى رفض كل مخرجات
سايكس بيكو ويطالب بتوحيد الامه الكرديه
هنا هناك ايضا الحزب الديمقراطي
والكردستاني الذي انشق قبل السنه سنوات عن
الحزب الام حتى لاسباب تنظيميه واخرى
ميدانيه ما زالت محل بين الحسبين حزب جمله
الكردي اليسري المعارض لطهران تاسس عام
1967 وكان من ابرز المعارضين لنظام الشهر
منظمه خابات القوميه الكرديه وتعني الكفاح
المسلح
وترفع شعار الحكم الذاتي لاكراد ايران
وتطالب بحقي تقرير المصير حزب الحياه
الحره بجاك قوه عسكريه فاعله منذ عام 2004
وينشط في مناطق حدوديه عراقيه مجاوره
لايران وتركيا ضمن مثلثي سلسله جبال قنديل
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس زياد
ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه
الامريكيه في باريس مرحبا بك دكتور زياد
نبدا بسؤالك عن قراءتك
لهذا الاستهداف المتزامن
من ايران ومن تركيا
للاكراد في كل من العراق وسوريا كيف يمكن
قراءته
اولويه على المساله الاوكرانيه ان تحسنا
من شروط التعامل مع قوى تعتبر كل من انقره
وطهران انها تهديد بامنها القومي طبعا
هناك خالق ااه يعني الاتراك لديهم حضور
عسكري داخل سوريا وبالتالي هم على اشتباك
مباشر مع الاكراد اضافه الى العمليات من
خارج الحدود في حين انها ايران تسيطر او
همم تساهم في السيطره الاقليميه على
العراق انما تستطيع في نفس الوقت ان تضرب
في شمال العراق من دون ان تحرج او ان تؤثر
على علاقتها بحلفائها في بغداد
المساله الثانيه هي ان تركيا وايران
تعتبران ان عدد من المقاتلين والمسؤولين
الاكراد في سوريا وفي العراق هم من
الجنسيه الايرانيه او التركيه وبالتالي
كانها كانهما تصفيان حس الداخليه مع خصوم
لهما تتهم كل عاصمه الاطراف المعنيه بانها
مسؤوله اما عن تفجير او عن تحريض على
الثوره الدائره في ايران اليوم بالنسبه
الى تركيا الدكتور زياد كيف يمكن قراءه اا
نوم الرئيس التركي روسيا اليوم بانها لم
تنفذ اتفاقات سوتشي فيما يتعلق بالمقاتلين
الاكراد خصوصا في ظل التقارب التركي
الروسي في الفتره الماضيه لاسيما فيما
يتعلق بملف اوكرانيا الحرب على اوكرانيا
العاصمه التركيه بقياده اردوغان ايه تحاول
باستمرار ان تعيد التموضع وفق التوازنات
القائمه بفتره
لفتره الرئاسه التركيه تلوم الولايات
المتحده على دعمها للاكراد وتتقارب مع
موسكو ومع سهران الكوري والان روما وجود
علاقه جيده بين اردوغان وكوتين ورغم بيع
اردوغان باسلحه متطوره درون تحديدا
اوكرانيا يريد ان يظهر في سوريا
ضد الاكراد بعد ان فشل في اقناع الروس في
ذلك كان هناك اتفاق في سوشي على ان تبعد
روسيا قبل عن مناطق التي تسيطر عليها ولم
يحصل ذلك امريكا سحبت بعد قواتها من
الشريط الحدودي وانتشرت في الشرق في منطقه
النفط وعلى حدود العراق يريد ان يقول انه
لن يضرب مناطق فيها حضور امريكي لكن على
روسيا ان تاخذ ذلك بعين الاعتبار لان
التقاربا امريكيا تركيا في سوريا
وهو يرفع ارشده التفاوض قبل اي عمل ممكنه
باختصار شديد ما فرص ونطاق التصعيد في
الجبهتين باعتقادك
اعتقد اننا سنبقى على هذا النوع من
التصعيد قصف مستمر تظهر خلاله انقره
وطهران حزما ضد خصومهم لكن لا اعتقد ان
عمليه عسكريه واسعه ستجري قريبا انما
تركيا تريد ان تحضر لها وان تربح المزيد
من الوقت في اتصالاتها الدوليه لتنفيذها
في حين ان ايران تنتقل من الاكراد بسبب
ثوره شعبيه ضدها
وبالتالي يستمر القصف لكن دون عمليات
اوصاف شكرا
من العاصمه الفرنسيه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني بلنكن
ان كاس العالم الحليب تاريخي كونه ينظم
لاول مره بالشرق الاوسط مضيفا انه متحمس
لرؤيه كيف تبني الرياضه جذور الثقافه
فيما نسميه الدبلوماسيه الرياضيه نستخدم
رياضه وسيله لخلق روابط بين الناس وخلق
روابط بين العالم وبلدنا لقد جلبنا لاعبين
ومدربين قطريين الى الولايات المتحده في
اطار برنامج تبادل وسوف يصل الى قطر خلال
بدعه اسابيع لاعبون ومدربون امريكيون
اينما ذهبوا عبر العالم نلاحظوا ان
الرياضه يمكن ان تجمعنا وتوحدنا وتخلق
روابط بيننا
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه هذا موجز
باهم الانباء افاده مراسل الجزيره في شمال
سوريا بان المدفعيه التركيه في ريف حلب
الشمالي قصفت بشكل مكثف محيطه مدينه تل
رفعت التي تسيطر عليها ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه وكان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان قد قال ان القاده العسكريين
يبحثون تنفيذ عمليه بريه للقضاء على ما
وصفها بالمنظمات الارهابيه
وقتل شخصان احدهما طفل اسرى سقوط قذائف
على منطقه قال قميش التابعه لولايه غازي
عتاب وقال المدينه ان القذائف استهدفت
المناطق السكنيه واطلقت من مناطق سيطره ما
تعرف بوحده حمايه الشعب الكرديه التي
وصفها بالارهابيه
قصف الحرس الثوري الايراني مقار داخل
اقليم كردستان العراق قال انها تابعه
لاحزاب ايرانيه معارضه تدعمها واشنطن وتل
ابيب وفيما دعت الخارجيه الايرانيه حكومتي
بغداد واربيل لتحمل المسؤولياتهما تجاه
ضماني امنها قالت الخارجيه العراقيه ان
الهجمات الايرانيه تعد خرقا لسياده العراق
من جانبه طالب برلمان واقليم كردستان
حكومه بغداد بالوفاء بالتزاماتها بحمايه
كل اراضي العراق
اعلن فريق خبراء الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه تسجيل اضرار كبيره بمحطه زبروج
النوويه في اوكرانيا الفريق الذي كان قد
اجرى تقييما لحاله المحطه او ضحانا مفعلات
المحطه مستقره حاليا وانه بصدد تقصي
مستويات الوقود والنفايات المشعه
اكدت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زاخوروفا ان الوضع في محطه زبروجها
خارج للغايه ودعت المجتمع الدولي الى
اداره طرف المسؤول عن الوضع الحالي في
المقابل دعا رئيس
الاوكرانيسكي حلف الناتو الى ضمان حمايه
مفعلات النوويه الاوكرانيه مما وصفه
بالتخريب الروسي
ابدا مسؤولون في الناتو تخوفهم من ان تكون
بولندا هدف روسيا التالي بعد اوكرانيا
وكذا رئيس اللجنه العسكريه في الحلف وجود
نقص في البنيه التحتيه على جبهه الشرقيه
من جهه اهداء الامين العام للنيت وادول
الاعضاء الى رفع الانفاق الدفاع وطلب
بالحفاظ على وحده مواقف اعضاء الحلف
نهايه حصاد هذه الليله شكرا على حسن
متابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]